il n'est pas question de contrôle reste
là c'est une relation basée sur le
respect ces animaux se disent je dois
manger je dois à chasser je dois il ya
bien de ces besoins que vous ressentez
aussi
chaque fois que lui dévoilant une
nouvelle attraction la fréquentation
augmente
c'est énorme
la direction a estimé que le mélange
génétique boosterait l'effet waouh
ce sont des dinos effet waouh t'es chat
garantie on l'a conçu plus imposante que
le t-rex qu'est devenue sa soeur elle
l'a dévoré nous avons un sujet au
confinement
qu'est ce que c'est son implant gps sol
est arrachée comment at elle pu y penser
et se rappeler où l'avait posée elle tue
pour le plaisir
vous savez pas mille visiteurs
il n'avait plus pataud
et pas les armes nécessaires
si on fait ça
offert ma manière
on a su corriger on allume
un problème et communique aux crues
salut jamais qu'un animal
d'une intelligence hors norme